hey reject nation how you doing it's
Greg Alba here and I'm John we're gonna
watch a video from Aldo Jones I got a
weird virals video that he personally
sent us he wants us to check it out hey
Joe before we do that I want to get a
page from the day shout out to a man
named Tyler is the actual pronunciation
thank you for for really learning that I
don't know how to pronounce her last
name buddy waiting for your last message
back so I could have asked you to do it
we've been messaging a little bit on
patreon he's a fairly new page Franta
jack guy is a huge gamer he's really
into movies we were talking about films
were really looking forward to ant-man
and the wasp one of the movies he's
looking most forward to this coming
summer so yeah shining him out and a
Mark Ruffalo related video Hulk just
makes so much sense buddy thanks for
following me on Twitter and I appreciate
me following you back because that shows
I am humble to follow you back sit down
right aren't I great the shoutouts not
about you Tyler it's about Greg you be
humble YouTube or do it's so great at
your humbleness I love your probably the
humble and maybe me more let's watch
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
truth is I am
[Music]
this is so cool
[Music]
intensifies oh yeah double double the
new spider-man Wow
[Music]
be stuck in my head
[Music]
which this was a br video I want to give
this song in a club
no creepy
[Music]
they're a bunch of Easter eggs and this
one like there are the others Wow you
guys can watch the full video and in
full screen format if you want to see
the last 20 seconds of this part of the
video but that is worth watching the
link will be in the description box to
watch this in full screen format the
whole thing you got it you got it if
it's your first time just watching it
here yeah you know I was thinking about
it while I was watching it this is that
rare thing where so many times you could
see the punchline and the joke coming -
Mark Ruffalo's head appearing but it's
still funny yeah like I think it's
because it's tied together by a song it
worries it nullifies that part of your
brain that gets bummed out when you
expect something and it happens because
then it becomes a fun game you're like
oh I bet it's gonna pop up on this beam
and does it's gratifying
oh yeah and like it's even the placement
of certain things you know this also
does make me think about how Mark
Ruffalo I used to view this guy as just
this really quiet calm dude who had this
leafy persona and like super dry
delivery on any John Rowe film it wasn't
has always seemed tired I don't know if
I'm just influenced by Aldo Jones's
consistent inclusion of we don't
[Music]
constantly doing that but then I see him
in interviews now there's a lot more
goofy - ever since he's been part of the
MCU what he sounds like a putter around
those interviews like dropping like
weird spoilers left and right wait till
you see this next one everybody talk to
do know he's got a weird
he's very goofy now it's cool to see
this this side of him it's just such a
shift from what I've associated him to
be as for so many years in the public
eye especially as like a really kind of
serious calm dude but this video too is
also thinking this is probably harder to
piece together you might you might think
that it's not as difficult to piece
together because like oh yeah she's like
taking clips and throwing Mark Ruffalo's
head here doing some weird graphics once
in a while
unlike the trailers where he can just go
scene by scene in a trailer and then
whatever pops into his head he could do
something weird and whacky with it you
know go crazy with his imagination he
has to find the clips from a variety of
different films and know when to include
it to make it match mix it up like this
it was a bigger homework I think to do
yeah cuz it seems like you know the
trailers he's got stuff to play off of
it's like you know we added a video it's
like oh here's a word or a moment I'm
gonna throw a weird thing there to
reference it but in this it's like he's
got a kind of structure this random meme
video yeah I was thinking about that
during the scene where everybody's
pushing the levers forward and Mark
really intensifies I was like we
probably to come up with like a loose
plot line for this video and then
cultivate clips to go along with that
yeah yeah that's actually time-consuming
it's very time-consuming the scenes
process of it and then there's all the
animation I think whether something like
this where you you you can just pull
from any film you got to know the right
felt like you know thinking about a
spider-man pose loved his master and
Kirsten Dunst or homecoming when he
replaces vulture with Mark Ruffalo and
in spider-man's at the door basically
the spider-man scene yeah like it's a
night show moment and everything like
just knowing what exact movie clips
would work or this yeah to make this
weird me me music video flow and be
fluid in anyway yeah this is actually
very fluid in life
this song's gonna create a song singing
a song yeah yeah did you create this
song all by yourself do you have help
with the song I think there's like some
bacon loop yeah like I wasn't kidding
this is gonna be stuck in my head
doo doo doo doo doo doo all right well
out there Jones thanks for sending that
our way man
very impressive stuff a plus me Murray
you guys can subscribe to Aldo Jones
watch this video please give it a view
you could subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification Belka subscribe
buttons do not work and you could check
us out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron eject to die